hi guys I'm here to show you what your  IELTS test a will look like let's go to  the centre  [Music]  here we are at college Attica where  you'll be taking your IELTS test let's  go inside and see what happens next  alright let's just jump the queue and  I'm going to show you what happens  inside money make sure you don't have  anything in a pocket no watch no  telephone just your water and your ID  card or passport did you see that I have  to carry just a bottle of water and my  passport no watches we can't carry coins  because if you drop the coins it's going  to make a noise just our ID and a bottle  of water nothing else  this is what the registration room looks  like you were good for the ID chair and  then we'll take a picture of you once  your ID has been checked and your photo  has been taken we come to the exam room  like these guys that are sitting ready  to take the test all of us here at the  position comes in you should  [Music]